hi and welcome to ontology talk i'm adam
pease and today we're honored
to have dr joseph urban with us uh
dr urban is a researcher at the czech
institute of informatics
robotics and cybernetics and he's been
heading an eu project called ai for
reason
prior to that he was a postdoc
researcher in the netherlands
and an assistant professor at charles
university in prague
and a marie curie fellow at the
department of computer
science at university of miami welcome
joseph
hi adam good to see you yeah great to
have you here
um so i thought we would get started
maybe just uh
talking about this project that you
finished it's a really major project i
mean a five-year project with lots of
participants
and as i understand it it was largely
about combining
theorem proving and machine learning so
very groundbreaking stuff
can you tell me a bit about the project
goals and accomplishments
oh yeah so the project is called ai for
reason
it started in 2015 in september
it's a project called
erc consolidators so erc stands for
european research council
so these are big relatively big
individual projects awarded by
this sort of european uh funding
agency and uh
it's it's sort of a touted as high high
risk high high value projects so you're
always supposed to promise
something some sort of moonshot and then
convince them that you have a decent
chance to do it and then work hard
on trying to do it so in this case
it was about combining machine learning
and automated reasoning so
i basically wanted
to see how how far we can push the the
power of automated reasoning and in
particular
automated tier improving by learning
from
a large mathematical corpora like
imaging something like mathematical
textbooks basically so so so the basic
argument
is that humans are good improving heart
theorems like
fermat's last theorem or
whatever classification of finite simple
groups like
all these great achievements that
mathematicians are capable of
because they study and they think and
they somehow combine
trying to solve problems with learning
um
from from their attempts like both the
successful and the unsuccessful ones
and like what i have been trying to do
basically since my
master's or phd work was to somehow
emulate this combination of learning
and reasoning on on computers
so so that that's like the main page so
we
uh took some
relatively big mathematical corpora
which would be like an
approximation of the mathematical
textbooks
and we took um
various automated theorem previous like
ultimate
like improvement for example or simpler
keywords like
link up like the connection system
and we equipped them with
internal machine learning guidance so
that was like the main
thrust of of the project where probably
the biggest
breakthroughs uh so so for example
in like two years ago we
we finally made it very quick
so we equipped eprover internally with a
guidance using gradient booster trees
which is like fast but state-of-the-art
machine learning system
and trained it on like let's say 100 000
previous proofs and run it in several
proving and learning loops like as it
proves it sort of generates data and
then you
learn uh train train the guidance on
them and then you proof again and you
prove more
and uh in in that mode
it it gave us something like a 70
percent improvement from the original
good improver strategy which was solving
something like 15 000 problems over
miser
in the like sixth iteration it could
solve
seventy percent or something like twenty
five thousand
so so that that was probably the biggest
breakthrough and that probably
uh shows what we are doing we
like in in the final evaluation that we
finished this like one month ago
we basically increased the overall power
of like various portfolios and
combinations of brewers
over this large missile library like
from
40 percent of proof theorems to
something like 60 percent of
uh through theorem so so the the sort of
overall outcome of the project is like
almost 50 percent improvement of the
power
of automated theorem brewing over
such a large corpus where you are
allowed
to to sort of do these things to to sort
of train
from previous brewers wow fantastic so
and and uh maybe i should just actually
take a step back in case we've got uh
viewers that are watching that maybe are
not intimately familiar
with uh you know formal mathematics or
even with fear improving
let me let me try to give you my very
layman's uh summary of
what's what the objectives here are so i
take it that
you know if we if viewers have
you know had high school geometry right
they were doing proofs in high school
geometry
uh maybe proving that one triangle is
the same because the side the angle and
side are the same
hopefully that rings a bell to people
but instead of doing a little proof of
you know seven steps mathematicians like
if they're proving a big challenge in
mathematics something like fermat's last
theorem
i think that that took like hundreds of
pages
of of uh mathematical steps each one
provably true from the next but going
gradually from the question
that's being asked to the answer
using all the things that we know to be
true about math
and if we can get machines to help with
this process
we can hopefully advance mathematics and
and uh
have more answers to more hard prep
problems in math
because then the human mathematician has
a good assistant
and it sounds to me like what you're
doing with the machine learning
is instead of having sort of you know
the worst case mach
theorem prover that just does a blind
search you know applying any kind of
truth in mathematics it can think of
well they're better than that right they
have heuristics
um but you've sort of improved those
heuristics so now you're getting a lot
more
and faster answers yeah yeah exactly so
you
sort of nailed it so indeed like
uh we we do not have a fully formal com
computer verified proof of the fermat's
last theorem
that's sort of the last missing
achievement or a milestone in the world
of formalization but we have
other great achievements like totem
hills
who is a great mathematician
uh working at the university of
pittsburgh has
proved in late 90s
with his student
the kepler's conjecture which is uh
which has been an
open conjecture about the optimal
packing
of balls uh in in the space
and yeah i remember reading about that
right yeah so it's like you've got a big
box
and you've got a number of spheres i
guess i think of different sizes that
you can pack into
of of the same size the same size that
you can pack into the box and you know
yeah
if you if you could have a robot
laboriously arrange them
how many could you fit in in the best
yeah yeah
yeah so so there are several packings
that have the optimal density
but it wasn't clear whether there isn't
a better packing so so he used
uh sort of computers to help him to to
get the proof
like he did a lot of decent math and a
lot of decent like programming to
to get the proof and then when he did it
the mathematicians couldn't review the
truth so so that was quite
interesting situation because you got
the best
people in the field um meeting for
i don't know four or five years in a
seminar where they were reviewing the
truth
and in the end they said something like
you know like we have checked a lot of
the proof but it's so big that we
cannot cannot really say whether this is
a proof or not
and tom uh tom really
saw this as a buck and he decided
to to prove it formally to to replace
the human
referees with uh proof assistance and
it took him a lot of so so the formal
verification finished officially i think
in 2014
and it involved like 20 to 30 person
years
but indeed like if you it's it's now
finished so it's like formally
the proof is verified the kepler
conjecture has been certified by
by this very secure proof assistance and
if you look
at the sheer size of the proof so we we
have actually done
various experiments with this full full
proof of the
formal proof of the triple conjecture
it's billions
billions of inference steps so it's it's
really
uh it's it's really something which the
normal mathematicians never really
encounter
like expanding your human level proof
to these bottom bottom level modus
ponens
style inferences and counting how many
uh are there so so it's really brilliant
for
for a proof proof like this
we'll pause our conversation there and
return in our next segment for part two
of my interview with dr joseph urban